cette année 2023 commence par les nuits
de la lecture sur le thème de la peur au
programme lecture horrifique et jeux
d'ambiance les médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous propose
plusieurs rendez-vous comptent à frémir
à Voisins-le-Bretonneux s'amuser à avoir
peur à Guyancourt ou encore le swing des
tout-petits à Maurepas pour se faire
peur en musique et après les nuits de la
lecture la Nuit des Musées visite guidée
libre ou animations les musées yvelinois
vous invite à franchir leur porte pour
redécouvrir leurs collection
gratuitement et depuis plus de 20 ans la
ville d'Andrésy célèbre l'art à travers
son événement sculpture en Lille le
principe des artistes viennent exposer
leurs œuvres contemporaines de Paris à
Andrésy ballon de baudruche cordage ou
encore bois et scotch l'édition 2023
pourrait encore nous surprendre
direction la ville royale le Mois
Molière reviendra cette année pour fêter
le célèbre dramaturge il s'agira de la
27ème édition comédien et compagnie
talentueux seront au rendez-vous avec
des centaines de pièces pour faire deux
Versailles une scène à ciel ouverte
événements incontournable à Versailles
les Grandes Eaux Musicales cet été vous
pourrez encore profiter de la beauté des
jardins de Versailles et des bosquets
exceptionnellement ouverts au rythme de
la musique baroque ne manquez pas non
plus les grandes zones nocturnes de
mi-juin à mi-septembre qui vous
offriront un mémorable feu d'artifice
[Musique]
les Yvelines sont également dotés de
nombreux festivals ont commencé à
Voisins le bretonne avec de la musique
reggae la tour et les watts tranquilles
pour une septième édition si vous êtes
plus électro ne ratez pas le festival
électrique Park sur l'île des
Impressionnistes à Chatou la
programmation n'est pas encore finalisée
mais elle promet l'année dernière Martin
Solveig avait enflammé la scène
[Musique]
le même mois possible HR et le PEC
organise leur festival dédié à la
chanson française et francophone depuis
30 ans des grands noms full la scène
comme Juliette Armanet Véronique Sanson
ou encore Yannick Noah et enfin ce Grand
Chelem se termine sur l'île l'aumône à
Mantes-la-Jolie les olfactory festivals
devraient se tenir pour une cinquième
édition avec trois scènes et plus de 20
concerts l'année dernière ce festival se
distingue par sa programmation
éclectique